in this capsule we will approach the
problem of implementing mechanisms
reference for reasoning
probabilistic with Bezier networks
so the main use and networks
beziers it's basically calculating
posterior probabilities being
gave new observations to our
disposition
so by just doing event reminds
that an event launches too much if it's a
assignment of value to some of
random variables associate my
observations so for example I
could question me considering the
result of a battery weighs done for
a patient is what now the
likelihood that the patient in question
certain diseases associated with
random variable x so in what
follows I'll talk a little bit about comment
what we do this type of calculation has
commented what implements them and
in swimming I will use I
will be noted x the set of variables
random ones for which I'm doing a
racket
so I speak in all in this
that if it will not necessarily be a
only variable to you random variable
it could be several
but I will still use just
the letter x
ex could either be a set where a
single random variable so in my
example of now and that it would be is
what my patient's diseases
of interest that interests me or not that
will be launched at the start and towards the east
at war who are being watched and small them that
is going to be the values ​​that are done
observe so illegal
small it would be the fact that the test and
got the small result that it would be
watching this and I could
have several random variables that
will belong to my ensemble and know how to be
all the other variables that we are going
to say hidden hidden in this way we
not observe we're going to have to
marginalize and so that could be
among others variables yx on
hate bodies that have not been done so
for which we do not have the results
then a query because we can go
a request if we have
the inference of so the calculation of the
probability of variables of interest x
given an observation for the
random variables observed big a
good example of a rocket in our
example or with burglary was
alarmed I'm losing my husband at it not
reason I could say if I observe that
jean called me and that husband called me
are both free I could
ask me what is the
probability that is well and truly
burglary at home to undertake
the decision to what I call the police
then I go to my home or not in
this case if we did the math on
would observe that we started from scratch
point
this is what is really a
burglary at home so if we did
the calculation from the probabilities
we have fixed here
the institute is so the question this is
how are we doing this calculation
so we saw how to do it by hand
but how do we implement rey
himself
vehicle there we will have two approaches
there are two different types what we
could do some calculations of
posterior probabilities like that one
can make a difference that is accurate
the advantage that we have an exact answer the
disadvantage is that she hears from
calculation sometimes it can be prohibitive
it may require calculation times
who are too high too tall is this
what we will do is the method by
enumeration that corresponds
basically to what we've seen up
now so I'm going to give a little
more details about commenting what we
could implement this at a high level
and we will see rather a title of
approach that is going to be inference
approximate so when it's having
a rough estimate of
probabilities of inference and to see
specifically a technique based on
sampling and method in
question we will see is what we
calls the rejection method so the
exact method that could be used
which takes the simplest is the
inference method by enumeration
basically corresponds to what we have
done when doing calculations
in the previous slides the for
hand calculations for the
conditional probabilities
so if we are interested in referring
Variable distribution
of interest x in relation to
observations we know that this is the
probability joins x and e normalized
so divided by a constant of
alpha normalization which corresponds in
makes the probability that the variables
observed be equal to what I observe and
seven projectiles made it his flap
calculate one must marginalized paranoid
unobserved variable y
ok so the calculus gilles auger business
in fact if this calculation is here and I have
do it for all values
possible of x because I want the
complete distribution for all
possible values ​​of a variable but
of interest x also we know that these
terms their in a Bézian network that
can describe as a product of
conditional policy that are
extracted from the Bézian network
we go if we have n a random variable in
my bedding network that will match
make the product of hate probability
different and so that's so if we
wants to calculate a value a probability
like that well one way to do it is a
film simply to calculate the sums
conditional policy products
so I'm going to nap a sum
on what 20 on everything so the values
possible to
so if if I have if I have that name here
two variables y so moment y over one year
without a bad year this is the size of
together and that each of the variables to
an area of ​​authority that means that
I have sums on the size of y
elements and so that's it and in this case
here I have to make the product of all
conditional probabilities and the
number of policies conditional on
multiply if I calculated this
joint probability the savate to be n
is now I have to do this calculation
for all possible values ​​of x
to obtain among others my constant
standardization can get all my
distribution and the number of so the
number of possible mistakes to fix these
six deaths the earth of the domain of x this
would be allah number of variables in
x and so if I had to do this calculation
like that by listing all the
possible assignments dy is all the
possible assignments of x and then in
doing produces hatred probabilities
conditional
I will keep complexity in the worst
high codes once halls to
ex sizes later on from there
many say the earth is
all areas of the largest domain
so in the random dream code
binaisse of would be equal to 2 or even
marc in fact that unfortunately we have
something that is actually
exponential in the domain head
uh no sorry that is exponential
in the number of variables relative
to which we must make enumerations to
know livable x then the variables
that we do not observe it given that
practice often we observed there are
many of the variables that are not observed
it can not be catastrophic
and that's why we say that
the exact inference based on a reference
by numeration it is often a
difference that we will want to invite
site to avoid it's not really a
an approach that in some
applications will be usable at
mark that complexity in space and
from broadband to standard variables
of a terrible why because we have to
remember all the values
possible of great peace exaggerates a
certain value given 1 then the
number of destinations exceeded at the
number of variables in my set
x I will add that it's still
possible to make an approach a little
less naive than the one I just
describe where we would get complexity
that would not depend on hate
here that would simply be from above the
at the size of explodes tijd and y
I invite you to look at the book
are energetic to know
how may end teaching this is a
approach that will try to exploit the
do we have some certain
products that can be
updated within the sums
so you send an example so
imagine that we want to calculate this
conditional policy when
burglaries compared to legal yapping
true husband calls would equal so I want
rated shorter way and 6 to change
and curvy and mega lift the variables
hidden in this case if these earthquakes and
alarms and in what I have to calculate
this is the next thing are sure if
these alarms from the evidence of joigny on
all the variables / a constant of
normalization so a naive approach to
the implement
would consist in enumerating
all the values ​​of hesse and from to
then for each of the possible values
a burglary so for the box
is the co here was just onfray the sum
of probability joined on all
variables that breaks down a product of
peace of cp 2 sp2 gold knowing csp of j
knowing how to help m knowing to do so
all these products there for all
possible values ​​of earthquakes and
tears I will do it first for
burglary equals true I will do it in
second for burglary equal must
so that would give me the two values ​​of
numerator here and here he putting for
have my normalization constant but
I will just sum up my two
numerator elements what would I give
my calculation of the complete distribution
robbery I spoke earlier who who has
a way to have a variant a little
little more effective is actually this
variant when it will exploit it is
the fact that for example here I have not
always need for all
site values ​​has always multiplied
these five products such in fact I can
bring in some of the sums and push a
little more to the right to have multiplied
minus two digits in his father's and
use some calculations so between
others the sum on to play to insert
here instead the sum on is this so
the sum on his game to insert it here to
the place so since from here I
terms that depend on aces then
if I have terms that depend on
once again in the era of details
on it I invite you to consult the
but so a very simple approach this
would simply list all the
possible values ​​of the variables
of interest explain variables
hidden there for each of these
combinations calculate it the
probabilities attached is a
sure product of hate or so the number
of variables in this case 5 so who
produce 5 probabilities
conditional and therefore to make the
are associated then the standardization
I think of one quickly that there is a
approach that's as accurate but who
allows to get some in the network code
beziers with a structure for example
of extraordinary structure a structure
which allows certain accelerations
so there is an algorithm called
the lyre difference by elimination of
variables that allows you to get times
of calculation that are more appreciable
more convenient in an application
the general idea is again
to try to reuse some of the
calculations so if we calculated for example
this product here here good brands in
all sums and products that must be
do this calculation there he also does
in another place of our calculation
compounds and the idea here is
to use a kind of programming
dynamics to store his calculations
intermedia there to make them one
times so I invite you to crossroads
consult books specifically the
section 14 points 4 points 2 in the
book energetically to have more
details
on it
now we are going to look at the code
the approximate inference so one the
shoulders it is they basically
all the different methods
abuses in the general case
complete appetite so we'll talk about
improvements still interesting
for example with the algorithm
of variable elimination but when
even in the general case this is the
ference example your life complete what
does that instead in some
applications your must use a
rather rough approach makes a
more practical approach
the idea here the reason why one
may be satisfied with a
approximate reference is that between
others sometimes finally we need a
calculation that just needs to be
approximate that there is no need
to be exact to be able
to use our Bézian network
properly his interest are not having
exactly the probabilities on the
variables of interest but just to know
for example what is the value of
interest rates so the value small hic
what is such that the probability that
x be small and be the most
high given some
comments
so if I'm just interested in having the
this value there that the value of
enjoy the highest I may have
no need to have probabilities
exact an approximate probability has
maybe I'll be able to find
carmen the right solution
the real value of memorable of interest
who have the highest probability
so we're going to focus on
techniques based on a technique in
done based on sampling so
what we are going to do is we are going to
assign values ​​to variables
random from the piles of politics
conditional he'll do so
these associates essentially a
simulation of our gold Béziers network
actually offered several simulations
stochastic
then from the results of these
simulations there we're actually going to used
these simulations there to make a
estimate of
but probability of inference then the
method that we will see
more specifically it is the method
called jackson sampling or the
rejection method so the idea as I
said it's to use simulations
or in fact in our simulations we will
generate a complete observation of
all the variables in my network
vézien and then to estimate the
probabilities of inference but we're going
just use the fees like
standardized so the relative frequencies
from then so estimated from the
observations that I have shipyard that I have
simulated
so we know that the probability of a
certain assignment ex equals
exciting observation data its
correspondence is here so I take
marginal practices are the
variables y possible then I normalize
by a normalization constant the
the idea is that we will approximate its share
standardized frequencies that is to say
what do I imagine that I have generate several
observations so many values ​​2x
and even there is so I will have a list
of observation like that of simulation and
the from these pseudo unfortunately gives it
was giving there that I would have simulate and well
I will esteem the policy expresses a
some small value x being given
some values ​​of the variables
of observation them as being the number
many times in my simulations
I observe this value of x there and this
value of 1 for the variables
random which excelled in 1 / the sum
frequencies for any value expressed
and therefore frequency the sum of
high frequencies expressed values ​​and
so in other words actually it's going to be
the frequency of so the number of times
that I saw little x is small
/ the frequency not once I saw
the variables
the rights associated with observations
big e equal to small ok so
intuitively the idea is that that in
the bottom is that tells us if I did
several simulations no but ends
final simulations what is the
proportion of times I observe that
observed variables are equal to 1 on
the propensity of times where x vote equal to
little x but rather than make it a name
but finished twice I'll do it a
man finished twice then I'm going
use these frequencies their relative
so normalized as my estimates
own reality of posters ya of inference
so this technique of the asaples and
rejection technique it's a technique
of rejection to the extent that in my
calculation
here I will only be interested in
simulations or a subset
I am interested in the north under sets of
simulation or but variables that are
observed they are going to be exactly equal
at the observed value
so if I have other simulations where the
variables that belong to my
together they took other values
that does not fit little one but these
simulations are very much
throw would not be considered in my
calculation is the problem with that is that
it's a method that does not go very well
market if the event grand e equal equals
small 1,6 and events there he will pray
that is, there are very few friends
simulation that are such that the
variables the random variables
belonging to a big e are equal
exactly at my observed values
this is very few champions the
frequencies here are going to be very low and
there are other methods that are more
effective that requires less
of samples ie if I have
my event question error that is not going
need I have is champion is
really a very large number
of observations to have an estimate
which is close to reality and we do not
would not speak in this capsule team and
I invite you to consult the section
14.5 of the book to learn more
so here is an example of the use
of the method grid by rhji based
on sampling so let's imagine
we want to estimate what is the
probability that my random variable
this way to the real one since the
laboratory m be equal to true so
it's in a new Bezier network that
is this structure different so if
gfcm who do not have any ghk parents
actually compares m
geo that there are no parents either
but I was like parra o and h and so
in this case also to estimate this
probability when I'm going to do that
I will sampled from my network
beziers several observations I'm going
assign green values ​​to fh
oh and tea is in excess say I
lack it's just the samples
where m is equal to true hockey why
because it's only these colloquia
who put I'm interested in the
likelihood that you're gala true for
the cases where m is equal to bhl is so the
way to make his son and to go there
sequentially I start with generated
randomly a value of f
from its probability a priori and has
given its value the champions priority
h
from there championship dams
for F
so on until generating
everything but necessary variable so we have
an example here of an execution a
simulation or generate f is equal to must
so I do that by doing simulation
imagine that the way to do that is
kim heger so I have a generator of
random numbers in 0 and a bath this
that I do what generates a long
marathon by deflecting and then I check
is it smaller than the
probability that my variable part
random be equal
if it is the case of me to you I the
April sign otherwise I sign it wrong
in this case also for this simulation
lodges and get a result that f is
equal in depth the rest of that generates a
value for the random web h from
a value of f
the mm schedule in this case as
justice considers only the cases where m
is equal to April when if I get a
value of real games without dionne to
from his parents there is no
parents so because if I'm just doing
sampled for part 0.6 which
is the probability that or be equal to
free I was talking with a moratorium
general 0 and 1
for this simulation too I got
in the real parts of that I'm going
sampled simulate an assignment
worth to wear it from
ax and at the value I have
champion and previously know true
is true so in that if I
would change a number between 0 and a
random way
can I appear with the
probability of peace is equal to 1 by the
desired pt galabru knowing that or is
true is bought true because if the
parity is equal to 1 so necessarily
my operative and between is going to be more
little one so I sampled
price of which I continue like that where I
sung one of this variable to this
variable at this variable this variable
then I start again here we did
eight samples in all and to make
the estimate of the probability that you
es be equal address knowing that m is
equal April I'm just going to watch
what is the average of the cases where you
is equal to true we have that if I have six
times true here here here here here and here on
eight bodies in total
which gives me an estimate of the
probability drive there is the real
knowing that I do not care about haven and
0.75
because if we calculated after
answer we would get 0.71 so we see
that when if that gives an estimate
which is not too bad only with
a sample of 8 simulation and so
that's it and I want to remember it's very
important here in this case also all
my simulations that I observe it was
any case where m equals true so
I may have simulated others
other cases so I'm sampling again
m every time I support m is
equal to false when if I ignore the
simulation
so I'm definitely not used in
my frequency calculation finally he
there are different types of polls
of requests we can make a network
beziers we talk about rockets from
diagnostic
when you know the effects then when
we look for causes
so in what if for example if I
I was interested in the parity of
burglaries knowing that jean tigana
true that's a stylistic query
diagnosis because I have guys there
I call the guys there dre it's in
makes an effect then the cause of that is
if the burglary or not we can
also calculate other types of
take advantage of the prediction probabilities
so because if it's a train
know the causes and I would have
estimated the distribution on the effects
so in my specific example in this
would be the opposite case
I wonder about the distribution of
people call it sings burglary is
equal to true obviously we can calculate
joint or marginal policies
and as we saw this an example of this
would be produced and not conditional so
we package be a subset
variables for example on the
probability lady so I could
I was interested in this case to know
what is the proportion of time when
my alarm would sound for example in
a given year